Hausa Gomez - its latest [ __ ] na mattis
you heard all right so it really is a
difference playing this [ __ ] all night
man it really is and I don't but I'm not
necessarily a big fan of it this doesn't
seem to be working it all right well
we're just gonna have to do something
about that um wait let's get going down
in this hellhole
the code nice code man great code great
[ __ ] code best code patient 13 oh
where are we I don't [ __ ] man oh cool
6y ah I love glowsticks why can't I just
have fun with them I can okay looks like
we have to turn on the electricity I'll
nail that [ __ ] discover another
just like a like a baby like a like a
like a I know will like a went it
oh hello hello mr. bridge I feel like
someone puts you away for a reason does
he know who is talking to you Joplin
does he know that I'm famous I'm only
caring about the famous director reprise
like someone took it seriously like you
so arrogant now it's okay yeah is he
[ __ ] with me I'm not going in the
water
my iPad is new it's not water resistant
so we're outside now that's pretty cool
that makes me feel a little safer hello
guys can can I touch it I will touch you
boxes with ropes can be moved
uh-huh boxes would Realms campaign mode
what first aid babe mom oh oh
what are we gonna do with that oh what a
loser
I'm sorry I'm selling it heartily and it
makes us a lot of humanity I would think
flowers keep me safe I don't need flies
I'm not a peasant but hey God I like to
fly are you happy
oh we lit them clever girl
good job nice
thank God I didn't care their orangutan
boxes with ropes can be moved ah I'm
just going flying to go all right we're
gonna need to push you there I put the
flare up my back for one second and now
we can go yeah yeah thank you flag I
mean how else would it being ignited and
not ignited I think there's something
Sarah it's not telling me I don't know
about your breasts I can feel it in my
thing oh god I've gotta go down there I
feel it in my house then an amendment ha
Oh Oh goddamn I'm out of flares
listen bit they'll love this party baby
so are we supposed to collect remnants
here interesting what are we doing here
why don't we get we're gonna take a boat
home that's it
this kind of me mermaids I'm or like
evil dolphins pretty sure there's gonna
be evil dolphins do the miraculous no
creepy for us it's the worst thing ever
I hate creepy forest oh this is so
[ __ ] creepy oh yeah blood Oh back off
back off
either so fun you're hella better okay
it's burning jog we're in a nice little
jog of foam just wanna go home man okay
what let's go to that big old tree no no
inside my butt
I just know it's awful
Oh ah find me if you got inspired sitter
why is she not going away
there we go that's my last flare Oh
mermaids man's okay let's just go
I'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] or anything my
dad and I made that which we I love that
[ __ ] so [ __ ] much all right
Vonda said y'all and we found a Mara man
Joe Brian
I hear that [ __ ] skipping away losing
your shape the [ __ ] up my patience oh
[ __ ] me don't do it they didn't they're
not giving us any [ __ ] man we're just
gonna have to take a [ __ ] cool this
time around baby
Oh God not a fan of this life is my
stream you're talking a lot of [ __ ] man
I see one inside and how do we get in oh
god oh god she's just around the [ __ ]
deck just around the deck man this is
hope she doesn't follow us in no big
deal I'll just get it right here nice
not gold man I [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
that [ __ ] iron my throne man Jesus uh
all right I'm giving this one more
[ __ ] go
but only because I love your breasts and
only because I don't want to show myself
that I can do this and yeah
Oh for [ __ ] sake I just [ __ ]
started I'm not looking over there you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] man no I'm not
looking over there
you're not gonna distract me all right
what the hell is that blue [ __ ]
if Heisenberg was here right now he'd be
pissed someone was stealing his [ __ ]
what is that is that a graphical error
is supposed to be blue and [ __ ] I don't
know I don't care this is um blow I'm a
daddy I'm a dad and okay the trick about
the shadows is to not [ __ ] look at
them and that's what I'm not gonna
[ __ ] though ah hello mr. J hey hi
what's hanging nothing well I'm on my
[ __ ] way then or die [ __ ] okay I
have one player I'm not gonna [ __ ] this
up I'm still really confused about this
blueness it looks creepy
stop stop whispering please for [ __ ]
sake not into you get over it
I don't even know what I'm doing where
are the remnants what am i doing this
what is love baby don't hurt me that is
one okay one thanks G Wow so [ __ ]
kind of you she's probably gonna tickle
my ass now sorry I'm a little pissed I
escaped I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] off
there it is
all right well [ __ ] let's just beat
which in my necklace that's okay that's
[ __ ] it okay
I hate this [ __ ] place I hit it with
a passion okay let's just get in the
house real quick Ryan for [ __ ] sake
man don't I don't I don't I don't I
don't I don't I don't I don't I don't I
don't I maybe we don't have to go in I
have to shag oh you were just creeping
in here you lo ass tickler
okay we're definitely [ __ ] now if
something happens Oh God
three out of five baby oh oh there's
another [ __ ] house are you cereal milk
titties there are the sigil is there one
more please be in here oh god don't like
this my ass is about to explode
don't say [ __ ] like that piss that's
[ __ ] weird you're just weird man oh
god please be here oh I don't have any
flares why are you even telling me that
what is that sound what is that sound
what is that sound don't like men sound
God God God it got a god I gotta get
that boom boom boom boom boom boom don't
touch me you little [ __ ] don't touch me
I'm [ __ ] famous thanks for the flares
by the way really appreciate that you
would so kindly give me so many [ __ ]
players what yeah what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do huh what are you
gonna no you're just gonna keep chasing
me
I looked everywhere oh oh no go god man
don't [ __ ] me man don't [ __ ] touch me
don't do it
okay oh it's like you have to take a
[ __ ] from your [ __ ] face that's the
best way to ex cribe describe this ah
alright where's the sigil I [ __ ]
forgot it's here somewhere isn't it
I'm sorry for the vulgarities I can't
help it are you playing right now
technically we're playing together
just grab it oh that's so oh I don't
want to learn I don't even live load
this get a run for it I'm a man and men
don't get scared of stuff we protect and
we prevail and we are that little pee
pee pants nope that's right mr. Dahle
I'm a lady on the fire lady you are
indeed we shall go to the [ __ ] moon
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] a duck
and it's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's bad don't
do that don't report this video because
I said that okay alright don't look left
I goddamn it don't look laughing OH
oh god I hate I hate forests and I hate
riches and I hate dolls and I hate iPads
and I hate Steve Jobs I'm sorry Steve so
I just think you have it out for me I
Love You Man I'm kidding okay my okay
okay this is go
ah thank God that [ __ ] so oh it gets
worse
alright I'm gonna have to end it here
hope you enjoy watching that's been a
pleasure I'm gonna go and have
nightmares lovely breasts you've left me
to die watching back